do you remember when we used to walk
down here and all the neighbors used to
stare at us and we used to be and we
would just be one way they would look at
us like we were circus freaks but you
could tell they enjoyed it
and then I got off on 14th Street you
could hit a clickety clack of the hills
the life the light the Shadows we called
14th Street the straw and that was our
turf some people choose sex work because
they want to being a trans woman in the
80s a lot of us did not have a choice
people were not hiring people that
looked like me trans life in general it
was difficult I wanted to make people
understand the reality of our lives
through storytelling the one issue today
that obsesses New Yorkers crime
the were out on the street 24
7. it was really a very bad situation I
mean
I'm happy but instead of having sex with
them for money we don't know who so you
know everybody's a client I actually
gave fellatio to a man who was a cop and
after I was done doing his deed he
arrested me whether it was from the
police whether John there was a lot of
violence
killed by a John who dragged me for half
a block in his car we were on the front
line with the gay and lesbian Community
but you're not doing anything to help me
from getting attacked we knew we were
freaks to them I can't even believe it
there's like the things we had to do
the trans Community has been in survival
mode forever it's important that we all
get an opportunity too
Thrive we fought to be where we are the
system never gave us resources
we created the resources
we have always been last that's not
gonna happen anymore
you owe it to every trans woman before
you and everyone asking you to keep
pushing we were pushed out of the
neighborhood years ago I was determined
to make a film about the stroll before
we're gone
now we're talking about
became this I remember that oh he said I
remember that I'm sure you do what's
your name
you still got it